Brazil's presidential election will be
settled in a second round of voting on
October 30th that's after no candidate
took an absolute majority of votes on
Sunday
with nearly all of the ballots counted
the former president leftist Louisiana
de Silva has 48 percent incumbent
president the right-wing populist jair
bolsonaro received an unexpectedly
strong 43 percent
the moderate Simone Tibet is trailing in
third place with four percent
the tight race means voters now face a
tense runoff between the two leading
candidates foreign
for two very different kinds of Brazil
the mood is festive despite an
unexpectedly tight race many hope a
change in leadership will bring about an
end to economic hardship
at times for four years we have had a
government that doesn't love the people
that doesn't care for the people
supporters of left-wing candidate and
former president Lula hope K will make
good on a campaign promise to address
socioeconomic inequalities as well as
stem and alarming increase in
deforestation
you know that the economy is not good
that your quality of life isn't good but
the job market isn't good that the
health system isn't good we want to make
our country better again
Lula is remembered by some for the
economic Prosperity during his
presidency but supporters of bolsonaro
also recall Lula's conviction on
corruption charges a judgment later
overturned
there's a second round and we must work
it will be the truth against the lies
caught against corruption
freedom of bolsonaro against a
censorship of Lula
the Lola
bolsonaro has outperformed polls despite
being blamed for the economic decline
during his term bolsonaro has also faced
criticism for mishandling the pandemic
but the level of support for his
conservative brand of God country and
family politics is still high
and to put this result in perspective
I'm joined Now by Valentina sadar she
leads the work on Brazil at the Atlantic
council's Adrian Ash Latin America
Center thanks for joining us
bolsonaro proved the pollsters wrong it
would seem by performing so strongly why
were the predictions so off the mark
thank you for having me
um yes uh he did prove the polls wrong
in a way many of us are looking at the
polls and analyzing some of the things
that also happened in 2020 here in the
United States
um the polls were off by how the margin
that he was going to lose against hula
on the first round
um some predicted even the Lula could
win on this first round and that clearly
was not the case many are saying that
the expectation there was in the sense
of it so it's not the polls not
capturing they they
tactic voting that's what we call it in
Brazil is when people decide to go for a
candidate rather than someone that they
would actually be more aligned with so
they can actually not have this other
can take when um instead the one that
basically going for a against BT kind of
vote BT zula's Workers Party
having said that that not necessarily
shows um gives this extreme difference
not only that we also have some of the
shame votes um that's what we call it
when they don't want to necessarily
um announce that they are voting for one
versus the other so we don't necessarily
account for those votes I think that
happens a lot with far-right candidates
in elections everywhere but let me just
come back to bolsonaro could he now win
the runoff
I think it's possible I think that on a
second run
um he has a very a stronger chance of
winning
um as well I think that this hasn't
happened in Brazil for the longest time
honestly if ever
um of a second
um contestant actually turning the
election
um in the second round but I think it's
possible he is five percent away from
Lula um on the polls are suggesting but
then you also have when you're looking
to see money cabbage's
um vote which is about four percent and
then City bow means which is about three
percent
um that's a bit over seven percent of
the vote and then you have others there
to include too so he could he could
there is a possibility there that he
could let me ask you this you're
describing what sounds like a real horse
race and if you could briefly what kind
of campaigns do you expect the two
candidates to to conduct now
so I think that they will both be
especially Lula will be trying to signal
to the center I think that uh Alchemy
his vice president is actually going to
be an important figure in this sense we
have a Congress that is highly um that
was highly elected in terms of bolsonato
supporters and some right-wing
um candidacies there that were
successful so especially when we think
about a potential Lula Administration
this is also going to be a challenge
when governing
um in terms of the campaign itself I
think we're gonna we have to wait to see
what's the money in cerebrum is we'll
end up doing
um but then also looking and paying
close attention to those that abstained
um from voting this round and seeing if
that will change on the second round as
well as the blanken knows that were
about four percent abstinction was about
20 percent of votes or non-voters so
this is also something to look into in a
specific important data to to pay
attention to okay we look forward to
talking to you after bat runoff
Valentina cider from the Atlantic
Council thanks so much